Hi Mystery recapture Today I'm going to
explain a Korean horror film called
Death Bell spoilers Ahead What shout and
take care
at the beginning of the movie a high
school girl Named Ina Wake up from a
terrifying dream She Live
It Is The Last Day of  Their midterm
exams so The students are on Edge The
teachers wenchang wook And The leachi
Young are taking a Last The exampapers
in saffran Way Great Another teacher
Named Choice so Young Who inclames Is A
Very uptide person Ina is in the Class
revising Before The test When  she get in
argument with her rankings she has
never had a good relationship with Them
because They are privileges and spoiled
by there was the parents The Class Can't
he on arrives late and jumps over a Wall
to enter the school the test finally
starts but  Only some minute Slater Joy
fine's Can't he on randomly drawing on
his answer sheet She Tears The paper and
ask Something Get Out ifnit interested
in the test in another room twin
monitors The students as the invidulator
A Boy takes beyon Here Strange wespers
have someone  asking for help he Looks
Down It his paper and this started but
a pair of Eyes stearin at him he False
the floor and Terrier And Wrong help Sem
up he notices self And flickted cuts On
beyon's rest and ask somebodded the boy
weirdly says that it was  her Who did 10
minutes Before The test is supposed to
be Over The ballering's Following nad a
funny song about this school plays On
The Speakers The teachers and the
students Laugh and the ABC serdity of
the situation It turns Out They Canis
responsible for falling a prank  and for
the taste the princeable Hold The meeting
for all teachers in Farming Name Of An
Academic competition taking Place 10
Days Later They welcome students with
students of Another prestegio school so
winning The competition is crucial to
maintening the schools reputation for
this purpose whang is given  the
responsibility to provideo students with
propper training starting this coming we
can't on the Rift top and her best friend
You And Me An Hero playfally Joker round
There approach By hang heung he gives
Them too fake ideas and the white Them
To A Club Can  't he on has a Crush on Ina
Which he doesn't try to hide One Day
Before The Special Class start The names
of the top 201 scores The bast In The
Last exam Right or Looking At The
results Beyond Again Here someone
Whispering he Looks  Said Enough and
hallusinates her face Turning into a
ghost decide freaksem Out And he atax in
He is drag the way by the student
Following nad an ambulance is called for
him to be take away to the hospital well
Being Pod Into the vehicle he tells The
students  that There All About To Die
everyone In The School Of Leaves For The
Weekend except for the Seasons you have
to item The Special Class Ina And Me
Young Hero are also a mongame Young Hero
doesn't like the fact that There are
Stuck When I all  other stins Are Going
To Have Fun For The Weekend hands At
Night They Sneak Out Of The school
using There fake ideas
at the same Time Dis security Guard of
the school find beyon in the ruins
nearby He is somehow escaped from the
hospital  He has a Blood all over his
hand and he Runs Away on Being Caught
The Girls me can hear an in the club and
the Dance With Him on my Long The
Following Day everyone gathers for the
Special Class joinotices That a girl
Named High Young is missing  but She
starts The Class Without her I Another
student Named Song Dong Hills to the
washrom and is attacked by someone He is
injured and drag than The devant unknown
to everyone Else in the school De
students are watching and educational
video on TV When Oliver Satin the  video
of Hi Young trapped Inside The Glass box
his Sean the outside of the box has a
Mass a quation Red knocked the students
freecout and Inner Runs to called wang
and the Lee from the saffran They try to
call the police but the internet
connection and phone  Line above Dad
that someone makes and Ann speakers
saying that the students will be given
questions Every few Hours if they failed
the answer they will die won after
Another The personal so Wants Them To
Stay Inside The School of Promises for
There Own Safety The Box High  Young is
trap Them starts The fill with water
label Leaves They prankster can is
behind of There's he Starts To abuse him
physically but stops When he sees that
High Young has DN Only after her daugh
he will Leaves that it mustand be one of
Can't  he on silly Pranks Silence
prevails in the classroom has the
disgustation do you Next leavers To Run
outside the school And Call The Police
from a Sharp nearby He is warrend by Joy
But he incest stereo is no other Way
after he Leaves The student rebel and
ask  to be Light Out Of The school
because It is two Dangerous as They Star
Running tords The exit a heavenly injur
delay Runs Inside and Dice in hoyx Arms
a glimpse from the hallway's chooses that
Beyond is also Inside The and Could Be
The One Behind all of  this students
Freak Out after seen Lee die Right then
someone From The Speakers Ones Them to
go outside the Guy Who is drag the way
earlier songdong Is made to back for
help From The Speakers of The students
are Ask to the second Question Which
reed correctly will  save song Dogs Life
They Run To The otherium like They are
told Troy asks dissecurity Guard to go
The Other Way and find the way to
contact someone The others one of time
but for the canaze with a second
Question Because of There's song Down
Here is brutaly  Killed after having hot
wax for the all over his Body moments
later He is dropped to the ground from a
hide the students are horrified at the
side of his tortured Body the answer the
second Question Is in graved on his
chest Before They can even More in  his
Death They find That a Third student
Named ji-wook is missing They register
that he Is The Killers Next Target in a
suddenly realized Something and r de
computer lab as Can't he on follese
Behind She Goes three The Last Of tupper
is from  no last exam and find that the
Killer is harding this According to
Their Rank This Means That She Will Be
The Killers Faith targets and group of
students plant a Hide and the dorms for
Safety Did You Know What the solve
anymore questions If It means saving
There  Life's daybell Leave that No One
know his There but Beyond is Red outside
the dorm room Laughing at Them The
remaining students split into groups
to look for the brass student last
searching choy accidently Heads The
security Guard Who is tracking for Cell
Fun plugs shepologizes and  continuous
Looking What the Group It is nabin sex
Hours since trywoods Disappearance
saturnally someone Banks on the Door To
The dorm room and Create a hollene It
One Guy Who a Fairly has never watch The
Scary Movie in his Life carefully Goes
The Ward the Door To Shack  When his head
is polte Inside The others Yell in Fear
enviting One Of The groups towards Them
The Light Set the Flicker making The
Studen en ik even More when everything
Goes back to normal They Seat at the Guy
Who is it hacked earlier is dead More
over  a girl Named suge Jin is also
missing The Other students with wang
reaches the classroom With The Third
Question has been prepared By The Killer
There Asked to find out They computers to
password by Looking At A bunch of
pictures They some help Figure out the
password but  When The computer turns on
a picture of giwoods dead body is
display A Long Side him hisc Figure Of A
Girl's Girls The Group Runs outside and
Meets The others Now all the students
are back together They Go to the schools
caffed here to eat Something and rest
talking about all the questions They of
gather and Tell now in a realizes that
the answers All Point Horse The Death of
Their Class Me One That happened some
years ago j1 Was A gifted student Who
Always came First in the Class She and
the now we'  re Best Friends and where
Always Together G1 want to get the
Scarlet shop because your parents could
Before to pay for To Vision The Other al
doens but in one-exam She Came sex
in her Class and didn't get this Color
shop She is  Found The Dad The Following
Day Back in the present this stone
seizoom the Killer is yuance Ghost yeah
that Check out the topic Sims sensitive
for wine he orders damn to stop talking
about you on insisting that there is no
such Thing Is Ghost somewhere else in
the  school The Girl Who recently
disappeared sougen his Being tortured
They and Grave the next answer on
herbody and putter Inside a washing
machine To Kill her that One hellevover
washing machine moments later The Battle
Rings in the kidding that the next
Question Is Ready to be having solved
Had A naf of hiding huang grabz are
Ranch and set af To Look For The Killer
with the intention To Kill Them himself
oh no other hand The students refuse to
Leave The caveteria to solve the next
Joy Ina and kan Are The Only Once
Welling to take  the rask the go to the
computer lamp and seed that the next
question is a Puzzle They salved in no
time and reveal that the answer is I
Know Who Killed me It Is Now confirmed
that The Killing have Something to do
with DJ Ones Death as wang  Looks with a
killer summon is Following him with Out
him Knowing the person It hacks And Out
Of The Blue But he manages To Safe has
Life and Run Away he Needs Troy and the
students on the stairs after wetch They
find sugens Body in the laundry room  It
is Clear The killar doesn't Care About
the right answers his Only intention Is
The Kill the students Which makes you
wonder Why bother with the questions at
all Following that Ina enter the Raymond
heroin and find a girl riding Something
In The Notebook She freaks  Out And Cause
The others but the girl has already
disappeared She's Sims that she is
hallucinating and dismisses the matter
Back in the caveteria everyone faus a
Sleep except for in his best friend Me
An Hero She is listening to music on
here founds because He is a  genius When
saturnally summon it hacksor and pulser
a
in the necklace that it is time for the
next Question This Means that Beyond
Wasn't The Killer after all the remake
There way to the pa room but see the
door is Locked and has a question right
now It they will have the solve The
Question to add with the room playing
list Is Cool And start The Grass Of The
banging on the door On The Other Side Of
The door is me on Hero Hanging upside
down From The Ceiling in a manages The
self  The Puzzle in Fine that the answer
is her Dead friend g-1 Studen
off making her bang her had on the
floorballow at last She also Dice we
that wasteing time when Fall As The
Killer and strangles her To Death
Looking At the dead body They find  that
The Woman is G Ones Mother The horrible
Night finally Ends and the next Today am
e memorial is how it for the dead stins
there walthy parents are also and the
otherium crying and the morning There
children's daughes meanwhile enowaks up
to the teres Where She finds  a bug with
g-wan's Family picture Inside She is
left to Shark to see that her Father in
actually The school security Guard and
the Mastermind behind the plan he holds
In A hostage and Locks all the entrances
To The otherium Following that he
anansas that He  is g1s father He has
been hearing Revenge For The Past Two
Years He is Happy that The Parents in
the otherium finally feel the pain he
Wants felt Than A video of g-1 Being
strongled The death is played on a
screen The Father asks The Killer  to
step forward or he Will Kill everyone
present There he let They Poison is gas
Into The Room a Flashback shows Us that
G1 had seen The wealthy Parents bridging
wang frquestion papers Because of this
G1 gets the sex position and this
qualified from the scarlishop program
she  can Friends wang and he kills her to
cover up his misconduct Beam had scene
him doing The Dead But he Never Spoke
for g-1 after watching the video Who
hang loses his Mind he's rats Stuart
hacks appearance because They with the
Ones you want it answers  from him The
security Guard finally fines out who his
Daughters kill your ass he's steps at
Side and kill's wang At Last The Ending
scene shows Us Father had been planning
the night for two hoy Year after his
Daughters Death subscribe From More
videos like this turn on  notifications
and Leave alike The Help The Channel Out
Thank you for watching